Shure:  你给的是那个靖蝎啊
Shure: You gave him that Jing Scorpion.
Shure:  你被这种人
Shure: You get it from people like this.
Nicous: 已经红了不知道
Nicous: It's already popular, didn't you know?
Katrina:  来吗修硕
Katrina: Are you coming, Shure?
俢硕：来了
Shure: Coming.
Tasha: 就差几个立场足
Tasha: Just need a few more positions.
Katrina:  就往就往这上面放你想要压的就行
Katrina: Just put it here, and you can press down what you want.
Shure:  我想压压一个哎
Shure: I want to press down one, yeah.
Katrina:  可以先放薄的花瓣可以
Katrina: You can put thin petals first.
Tasha: 一个两个还差一个立场足
Tasha: One, two, still need one more stance.
Tasha: 还差一个无敌啊
Tasha: Still need one more invincible.
Katrina:  这个我感觉也这样吧
Katrina: I think it's like this too.
Katrina:  就这样摆着就行
Katrina: Just place it like this.
Tasha: 哈哈他他打不过我
Tasha: Haha, he can't beat me.
俢硕：拿一个有设计感一点的
Shure: Get one that's a bit more stylish.
Tasha: 然后他还可以再跟我玩
Tasha: Then he can keep playing with me.
Katrina: 非常修身养性
Katrina: Very calming.
Katrina:  你那里有几片啊Lucy就是木板
Katrina: How many pieces do you have, Lucia? Just the wooden boards.
Lucia: 嗯我下下面那个是4片
Lucia: Hmm, I have 4 pieces at the bottom.
Lucia: 不过是小的
Lucia: But they're small.
Lucia: 上面只有
Lucia: On top, there's only...
Tasha: 嗯是的
Tasha: Hmm, yes.
Lucia: 我打算先放两个
Lucia: I plan to put two first.
Katrina:  我说因为木板啊
Katrina: I'm saying because of the wooden boards.
Lucia: 木板木板只有一个
Lucia: There's only one wooden board.
Katrina: 你就只有一片
Katrina: You only have one piece.
Tasha: 嗯乌迪尔
Tasha: Hmm, Udyr.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不过纸有很多
Lucia: But there's plenty of paper.
Katrina: 还要
Katrina: Still need...
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Katrina:  还有一个木板呢哦在这
Katrina: There's another wooden board, oh, here it is.
Tasha: 123 嗯
Tasha: One, two, three, hmm.
Tasha: 内脏桌也差一个
Tasha: The table's still missing one.
Shure:  然后这个可以摘是吗
Shure: And this can be picked, right?
Katrina:  可以啊但感觉这叶子不是很好看
Katrina: Yeah, but I feel like these leaves aren't very nice looking.
Nicous: 卖了卖了卖了卖了
Nicous: Sold, sold, sold.
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Who are you selling to?
Katrina: 这种小花就可以直接摘
Katrina: These little flowers can be picked directly.
Jake: 怎么还
Jake: How come...
Tasha: 谁卖谁啊
Tasha: Who are you selling to?
Jake: 还你是挂了吗
Jake: Are you disconnected?
Katrina:  我还有一个东西要做
Katrina: I still have one more thing to do.
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Who are you selling to?
Katrina: 我天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina:  这辈子没干过活这么多手工活
Katrina: I've never done this much handiwork in my life.
Katrina:  从小幼儿园的时候上手工课就不会做
Katrina: Since kindergarten, I was never good at craft classes.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就给糖给别人让别人做
Katrina: I would just give candy to others to do it for me.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 从小就会
Katrina: You've known this since you were little
Katrina:  这种雇佣劳动力
Katrina: This kind of hired labor
Tasha: 嗯应该不会吧
Tasha: Hmm, probably not
Katrina:  然后就很多年没有做过手了
Katrina: And then I haven't done it for many years
Shure:  这压出来是一整张是吗
Shure: Is this pressed out into a whole sheet?
Katrina:  没有压出来
Katrina: No, it's not pressed out
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: It's just
Lucia: 像这样
Lucia: Like this
Lucia: 就是它会变成一个一个干
Lucia: It will become one dry piece at a time
俢硕：啊 啊啊
Shure: Oh, oh, oh
Shure:  嗨
Shure: Hi
Tasha: 你看啊
Tasha: Look
Tasha: 它启动是慢
Tasha: It's slow to start
Tasha: 因为我带的装备不对
Tasha: Because I'm wearing the wrong gear
Shure:  我以为是构成一幅画呢
Shure: I thought it would make a picture
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No
Tasha: 不是带了个偷吗
Tasha: Didn't you bring a thief?
Katrina:  那那这些棒干了以后
Katrina: Then after these sticks dry
Shure: 那它这些棒
Shure: Then these sticks
Katrina:  再自己拼拼成一副画
Katrina: You can piece them together into a picture yourself
俢硕：棒有什么用呢
Shure: What are the sticks for?
Katrina:  当然你也可以发挥你的创造力
Katrina: Of course, you can use your creativity
Katrina:  然后之后你就拿它干
Katrina: And then after you take it dry
Katrina:  了以后它颜色也保存了
Katrina: The color will also be preserved
Katrina:  你就拿胶水粘那种明信片啊
Katrina: You can glue it onto postcards
Katrina:  或者什么都可以
Katrina: Or whatever you want
Katrina:  或者夹玻璃片
Katrina: Or clip it between glass sheets
Tasha: 他还有这种本领
Tasha: He has this kind of skill
Tasha: 他怎么可能会有这种
Tasha: How could he have this
Nicous: 卖了卖乌迪而
Nicous: Sell, sell Udyr
Tasha: 卖谁
Tasha: Sell who?
Nicous: 卖乌迪而
Nicous: Sell Udyr
Shure:  我试试来然后呢
Shure: I'll give it a try, then what?
Nicous: 冲  冲
Nicous: Go for it, go
Katrina:  没然后了
Katrina: Then there's nothing more
Katrina:  就把你压扁就行
Katrina: Just press it flat
Katrina:  不是你多放点呗
Katrina: Why don't you put more?
Shure:  什么叫多放一点
Shure: What do you mean by put more?
Shure:  这就是你的磁塔
Shure: This is your magnetic tower
Katrina:  这么多地方的呢
Katrina: So many places here.
俢硕：啊都可以利用
Shure: Yeah, they can all be used.
Tasha: 这就是你的磁塔
Tasha: This is your magnet tower.
Shure: 这些瓣也要压一下
Shure: These petals need to be pressed too.
Shure:  那这些棒也要压一下吗
Shure: Do these sticks need to be pressed too?
Tasha: 都受不了了
Tasha: Can't take it anymore.
Katrina:  我觉得第一层先压薄的吧
Katrina: I think we should press the thin layer first.
Katrina:  这个放厚点
Katrina: Make this one thicker.
Katrina:  先压薄的就一片一片摆上去
Katrina: Press the thin ones first and lay them one by one.
Tasha: 盖上一些小罐子
Tasha: Cover with some small jars.
Nicous: 我靠
Nicous: Oh my God.
Tasha: 这就是你的
Tasha: This is yours.
Nicous: 我要笑死了
Nicous: I'm gonna die laughing.
Nicous: 他有几根包管 录下来了吧
Nicous: How many pipes does he have? Recorded, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Nicous: 一会她就学会了
Nicous: She'll learn in a bit.
Nicous: 不要卖乌迪尔
Nicous: Don't sell Udyr.
Tasha: 要卖力曾主
Tasha: Sell Li Zengzhu.
Nicous: 要卖力曾主
Nicous: Sell Li Zengzhu.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Katrina:  你特别有一种
Katrina: You really have that
Katrina:  被妈妈送过去上那种兴趣班的
Katrina: Kid look, like when your mom sends you to those hobby classes
Katrina:  那种小孩
Katrina: That kind of kid
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  坐着乖乖的
Katrina: Sitting there obediently
Katrina:  你妈
Katrina: Your mom
俢硕：毫无感情是吧
Shure: Totally emotionless, right?
Katrina:  对毫无感情
Katrina: Yeah, totally emotionless.
Katrina:  等你妈来接你回家的
Katrina: Waiting for your mom to pick you up.
Katrina:  我是那老师监督
Katrina: I'm the teacher supervising you.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure:  铺完了然后呢
Shure: After laying it out, then what?
Katrina:  铺完了
Katrina: After laying it out,
Katrina:  然后就没有然后了
Katrina: Then there's nothing more.
Katrina:  然后就把板子盖上
Katrina: Just cover it with the board.
Katrina:  就
Katrina: And then
Katrina:  我看看再放一点
Katrina: Let me see, put a bit more.
Katrina:  放满充分利用
Katrina: Make full use of the space.
Shure:  好好的轩老师
Shure: Good job, Mr. Xuan.
Katrina:  怎么都叫我轩老师
Katrina: Why does everyone call me Mr. Xuan?
Shure:  又忘了你姓啥了
Shure: I forgot your last name again.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  没有没有记着呢记着呢
Shure: No, no, I remember, I remember.
Shure:  节目效果懂吗
Shure: It's for the show's effect, you know?
Katrina:  懂懂懂
Katrina: I get it, I get it.
Katrina:  主要是之前那男生也叫我轩老师啊
Katrina: Mainly because that guy before also called me Teacher Xuan.
Shure:  完了勾起你不好意思回忆了是吗
Shure: Oh no, did it bring back awkward memories?
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
俢硕：好的轩老师
Shure: Alright, Teacher Xuan.
Katrina:  哈哈哈你达到了
Katrina: Hahaha, you did it.
俢硕：轩老师
Shure: Teacher Xuan.
Katrina:  哈哈哈受不了了
Katrina: Hahaha, I can't take it.
Katrina:  他当时也这么叫我
Katrina: He used to call me that too.
俢硕：嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
Shure: 那人天真还是罪恶
Shure: Was that person naive or malicious?
Katrina:  这你就不知道了吧
Katrina: You don't know, do you?
Katrina:  昨天晚上新讲的一个
Katrina: It was a new story told last night.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  就是每天晚上解锁一个新角色
Shure: It's like unlocking a new character every night.
Nicous: 昨天晚上解锁啦
Nicous: Unlocked last night.
Shure:  解锁了就到时候七个葫芦娃
Shure: Once unlocked, there will be seven Calabash Brothers.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 昨晚我没来
Nicous: I wasn't here last night.
Shure:  就是白雪公主和七个小矮人
Shure: Like Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs.
Katrina:  所以
Katrina: So...
Katrina:  当时知道你们都是北欧的我惊呆了
Katrina: When I found out you were all from Northern Europe, I was shocked.
Katrina:  对我感觉这辈子
Katrina: I feel like in this life...
Katrina:  跟北欧脱不了关系
Katrina: I can't escape my connection with Northern Europe.
Shure:  其实我们都认识
Shure: Actually, we all know each other.
Shure:  就你说那个人
Shure: That person you mentioned...
Shure:  我们已经查出来是谁了
Shure: We already found out who it is.
Katrina:  放屁我才不信你呢
Katrina: Nonsense, I don't believe you.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun-dun-dun-dun.
Nicous: 颠簸群只要你想查就什么都能查
Nicous: In the rumor mill, if you want to find out, you can find anything.
Shure:  你先查查
Shure: You go check first.
Shure:  把王爱媛的所有名单调出来
Shure: Bring out all the lists of Wang Aiyuan.
俢硕：你快快调一下
Shure: Quickly, bring them out.
Nicous: 调你的 美女
Nicous: Check your lists, beautiful.
Shure:  跟杨老板申请申请
Shure: Apply to Jake for it.
Nicous: 申请用来干这个的
Nicous: Applying for this purpose
Katrina:  你是人啊
Katrina: You are a human
Shure:  我是狗好吧
Shure: I'm a dog, okay
Shure:  借了个纸你去做狗
Shure: Borrowed a piece of paper to be a dog
Katrina: 唉
Katrina: Sigh
Shure:  快下一步是什么
Shure: What's the next step?
Katrina:  就上一个板子压他就好了
Katrina: Just press him with a board
Katrina:  这就赶走了
Katrina: He'll be driven away
Katrina: 然后我觉得可以再再夹一层
Katrina: Then I think we can add another layer
Katrina:  嗯养老
Katrina: Hmm, retirement
Katrina:  生活
Katrina: Life
俢硕：就跟养老院似的
Shure: Just like a retirement home
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure:  哦这是汉堡的
Shure: Oh, this is for the burger
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Uh
Shure:  他散了
Shure: It fell apart
Katrina:  预示着我的爱情
Katrina: Like my love life
Katrina:  这样翻哈哈哈
Katrina: Flip it like this, haha
Katrina:  哈哈好的
Katrina: Haha, okay
Tasha: 关掉
Tasha: Turn it off
Shure:  好的轩老师哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, Teacher Xuan, haha
Katrina:  受不了你了
Katrina: I can't stand you
Jake: 什么老师
Jake: What teacher?
Katrina:  是他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Teacher Xuan
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Katrina:  他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Teacher Xuan
Katrina:  叫她轩老师
Katrina: Calls her Teacher Xuan
Katrina:  他是那种上补习班的小孩
Katrina: He's like a kid in tutoring classes
Katrina:  然后我是旁边老师
Katrina: And I'm the nearby teacher
Katrina:  他等他妈接他回家吃饭哦
Katrina: Waiting for his mom to pick him up for dinner
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure:  你直接坐一下不就得了
Shure: Just sit down directly
Lucia: 不行你要把这袋子拉紧
Lucia: No, you need to tighten the bag
Lucia: 哦你这意思我坐在上面拉
Lucia: Oh, you mean sit on it and pull
Shure:  对什么叫坐在上面拉
Shure: Yes, what do you mean sit on it and pull
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina:  好奇怪
Katrina: So weird
Lucia: 这句话能删掉吗
Lucia: Can we delete this line?
Katrina:  AI
Katrina: AI
Katrina:  AI听了点什么东西
Katrina: AI heard something
Jake: 一没有一点问题
Jake: There’s no problem at all.
Shure:  你不坐在上面拉也行
Shure: You don't have to sit on it to pull.
Katrina: 你做这个吧你来做这个行吗
Katrina: You do this, can you do this?
Katrina: 你做这个行吗
Katrina: Can you do this?
Shure:  你在拉里拉萨
Shure: You pull it anywhere you like.
Shure:  你在哪里拉随便你
Shure: Pull it anywhere you like.
Jake: 什么怎怎么翻译这个
Jake: How do you translate this?
Jake: 什么叫坐
Jake: What does it mean to sit?
Shure:  哈哈我不知道这叫什么
Shure: Haha, I don't know what this is called.
Katrina: 啊这是不是要热熔枪啊我靠
Katrina: Ah, do we need a hot melt gun for this? Oh my god.
Lucia: 别吧朋友们
Lucia: Don't, guys.
Lucia: 我的一世英名啊
Lucia: My reputation is at stake.
Shure:  sit sit谁
Shure: Sit, sit who?
Jake: 谁谁坐
Jake: Who, who sits?
Shure:  他他我我
Shure: He, he, me, me.
Lucia: 就这个我刚才想把它拉紧然后
Lucia: Just now, I wanted to tighten it and then...
Shure:  这不压了这个花吗
Shure: Doesn't this press down the flower?
Lucia: 不好意思不好意思不好意思
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  修硕说我可以
Katrina: Shure said I could.
Jake: 为什么要坐
Jake: Why do we need to sit?
Lucia: 就是坐在上面这样可以压得更紧
Lucia: Sitting on it will make it tighter.
Jake: 你你你sitting on
Jake: You, you, you sitting on...
Shure:  这样不是
Shure: Isn't it like this...
Jake: 你sitting on the board是吧
Jake: You sitting on the board, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:然后我说不行就这个东西要拉紧
Lucia: Then I said no, this thing needs to be tightened.
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure:  我也可以坐在上面
Shure: I can sit on it too.
Jake: P Puling with you sitting on it right啊OK
Jake: P-Pulling with you sitting on it, right? Okay.
Shure:  啊你先铺铺点
Shure: Ah, you lay it out first.
Shure:  这个还可以给他
Shure: This can still work.
Shure:  那什么给他谐音怎么POL
Shure: What's the homophone for this POL...
Shure:  噗那个噗脸
Shure: Po, that Po face.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我靠哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my god, hahaha.
Shure:  你这这中文是互通的有没有
Shure: Is your Chinese even compatible?
Jake: 有有有有
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  你不做完一遍了吗
Shure: Haven't you done it once?
Shure:  你怎么还需要学啊
Shure: Why do you still need to learn?
Katrina:  就这个啊
Katrina: Just this.
Shure:  这谁的花
Shure:  我就给人家薅了
Katrina:  我的全被我剪光了
Shure:  这个是谁的
Katrina:  我的呀哦
Lucia: 这个真的要弄的很紧吗
Jake: 什么时候做狗
Lucia: 做狗谁不会啊哈哈哈
Jake: 把什么
Jake: 我我有
Jake: 那试试
Shure:  不是他那个
Jake:好
Katrina: 是这样干的
Jake:什么4点的什么
Jake:现在有四点
Katrina: 问你一个问题
Shure: 你说
Katrina: 我想跟你说他不想谈恋爱真是
Lucia:哎那那哦我去
Lucia:怎么抓在这啊
Lucia: How do you catch it here?
Shure: 其中的是真的就是现在很忙很烦
Shure: One possibility is that he's really busy and stressed right now.
Shure: 然后还有一种可能就是
Shure: Another possibility is...
Shure: 他没那么喜欢你
Shure: He doesn't like you that much.
Lucia:我先简单的尝试一下
Lucia: I'll try to keep it simple first.
Katrina: 明白
Katrina: Got it.
Shure: 他只要不是现在特别忙那种
Shure: As long as he's not super busy right now...
Shure: 那就可能是后事当我瞎说了
Shure: Maybe I'm just talking nonsense then.
Shure: 这仅针对我而言
Shure: This is just my opinion.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And...
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 怎么了昨昨天就就那什么去了是吧
Shure: What happened yesterday, you went there, right?
Shure: oh
Shure: Oh.
Shure: do do do do do do steal
Lucia:这两边不一样紧哎
Lucia: It's not equally tight on both sides.
Katrina: 没事然后搞个密封袋把它密封住
Katrina: It's fine, just get a sealed bag to seal it.
Shure: 你看看是不是还得坐上
Shure: Check if you need to sit down.
Lucia:我这叫从善如流
Lucia: I call this going with the flow.
Katrina: 就摘你的花去
Katrina: Just pick your flowers.
Katrina: 我这开的好的都被我摘掉了
Katrina: I already picked the best ones.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这有点丑吧
Katrina: Hahaha, this looks a bit ugly.
Katrina: 这 这就直接这样呀
Katrina: This, this just goes like this?
Katrina: 也行好像
Katrina: Seems okay though.
Jake:小手法
Jake: Small trick.
Shure: 不每片花瓣
Shure: No, each petal...
Shure: 都有他自己的
Shure: ...has its own...
Shure: 可圈可点之
Shure: ...remarkable points.
Katrina: 滚 滚
Katrina: Get lost, get lost.
Shure: 就像谢彬竹一样
Shure: Just like Xie Binzhu.
Lucia:现在差不多了
Lucia: It's almost done now.
Lucia:good
Lucia: Good.
Lucia:让我看看它明天会变成什么样子
Lucia: Let me see what it looks like tomorrow.
Lucia:好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia:做法
Lucia: Method.
Katrina: 又刺激我了吗
Katrina: Are you teasing me again?
Jake:什么梗啊这是
Jake: What's this joke about?
Jake:哈哈哈什么梗啊什么梗啊什么梗
Jake: Hahaha, what's this joke about? What's this joke about?
Katrina: 他这人可贱了
Katrina: He's such a jerk.
Shure: 我就可以
Shure: I can...
Jake:说来听听
Jake: Tell us.
Shure: 就可以大家都听不懂的状态下
Shure: I can, when no one understands...
Shure: 然后精准的攻击到他
Shure: ...precisely attack him.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:可以
Jake: Good.
Shure: 哇我这些都开了
Shure: Wow, all of mine are blooming.
Lucia:Good
Lucia: Good.
Shure: 还有我本来就是开的呀
Shure: Mine were already blooming.
Katrina: 没问题现在已经是金刚之躯了
Katrina: No problem, I'm already as tough as steel.
Katrina: 无所谓我的心跟石头一样
Katrina: Doesn't matter, my heart is like stone.
Shure: 发青春
Shure: Youthful energy.
Katrina: 你也要耕鸡
Katrina: You need to plow too.
Katrina: 拿你的故事来换
Katrina: Exchange it with your story.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 你你顶多做母鸡
Shure: You can at most be a hen.
Katrina: 你猜他会放什么歌
Katrina: Guess what song he will play.
Katrina: 所以快递是他等会寄送过来是吧
Katrina: So the courier will deliver it later, right?
Katrina: 不用寄去
Katrina: No need to send it.
Katrina: 他不是想
Katrina: Doesn't he want...
Lucia:我们的笔到了吗
Lucia: Has our pen arrived?
Katrina: 他不是想去看小狗吗
Katrina: Doesn't he want to see the puppy?
Katrina: 谁带他去看小狗
Katrina: Who's taking him to see the puppy?
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:我没去过
Jake: I've never been.
Katrina: 克星
Katrina: Nemesis.
Lucia:我也没见过
Lucia: I haven't seen it either.
Lucia:我也没去过
Lucia: I haven't been either.
Katrina: 你要不跟他们去看小狗
Katrina: Why don't you go with them to see the puppy?
Jake:走带我们去吧
Jake: Let's go, take us.
Katrina: 就很近很近
Katrina: It's very close, very close.
Katrina: 走溜一圈嘛
Katrina: Let's go for a walk.
Lucia:可以换个鞋吗
Lucia: Can I change my shoes?
Jake:走上楼在抓一个人
Jake: Let's go upstairs and grab someone.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Lucia:不想穿拖鞋去
Lucia: I don't want to go in slippers.
Jake:三楼还有一个薇薇
Jake: There's still Tasha on the third floor.
Lucia:可能拖鞋会走着走着掉在路上
Lucia: My slippers might fall off while walking.
Katrina: 让我穿睡衣就能去
Katrina: Let me wear pajamas and I can go.
Lucia:这个放哪
Lucia: Where should I put this?
Shure: 睡什么
Shure: Wear what?
Katrina: 我说这能穿睡衣去吗
Katrina: I mean, can I wear pajamas to go?
Katrina: 算了不去晚上去
Katrina: Forget it, I'll go at night.
Lucia:这就放这吧
Lucia: Just leave it here.
Lucia:回来还得拼我的这个玩意
Lucia: I still have to put this thing together when I get back.
Shure: 从这捡是不可以
Shure: Picking from here is not allowed.
Katrina: 为什么你的颗爱心这么大
Katrina: Why is your heart so big?
Katrina: 我去我都是小颗爱心
Katrina: I always have a small heart.
Shure: 因为我的爱意更足
Shure: Because my love is stronger.
Shure: 危险
Shure: Dangerous.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我的荷尔蒙刺激到它了
Shure: 他们会被压到一起吗
Shure: Will they be crushed together?
Shure: 不会吧
Shure: Probably not.
Katrina: 嗯随便反正自已做自产自销
Katrina: Well, whatever, do it yourself, self-production and self-sale.
Shure: 这个剪刀有点不好使
Shure: These scissors aren't working well.
Katrina: 不知道啊他叫真就说他真的
Katrina: I don't know, he says it's true, so it is.
Katrina: 哈哈哈孔雀
Katrina: Hahaha, peacock.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Katrina: 这是我的蝴蝶风灵
Katrina: This is my butterfly wind chime.
Shure: 我们的轩老师可能好这一口
Shure: Our teacher Xuan might like this kind of thing.
Katrina: 轩老师轩老师
Katrina: Mr. Xuan, Mr. Xuan
Katrina: 在给别人做狗呢
Katrina: Acting like a dog for someone else
Katrina: 轩老师啊
Katrina: Mr. Xuan, huh
Shure: 懂了
Shure: Got it
Nicous: 我来恭喜你
Nicous: I'm here to congratulate you
Shure: 轩老师是不是会关注一个狗
Shure: Does Mr. Xuan follow a dog?
Katrina: 不是我觉得他好奇怪
Katrina: No, I think he's really strange
Katrina: 什么叫那种嗯
Katrina: What do you mean by that
Katrina: 一边问你在干嘛
Katrina: On one hand, he asks what you're doing
Katrina: 一边又跟你说自已不想谈恋爱
Katrina: On the other hand, he says he doesn't want to date
Nicous: 谁
Nicous: Who
Katrina: 一个男的
Katrina: A guy
Katrina: 他也不是纠节好小
Katrina: And he's not very conflicted
Shure: 我怎么能把它
Shure: How can I...
Katrina: 没有就是分手之后这一个暧昧对像
Katrina: No, just someone ambiguous after a breakup
Shure: 真的就这一个吗
Shure: Really just one?
Katrina: 真就这一个啊
Katrina: Really just one
Nicous: 你知道为什么吗
Nicous: Do you know why?
Nicous: 因为还在跟别人谈
Nicous: Because he's still seeing others
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too
Katrina: 可能就是在养鱼吧
Katrina: Maybe he's just keeping options open
Katrina: 无所谓啊
Katrina: Whatever
Katrina: 然后我就打算
Katrina: So I decided
Nicous: 真正的高手是他能同时谈
Nicous: A real player can date multiple people at once
Katrina: 嗯吃饭然后第二天就回武汉去
Katrina: Yeah, have dinner, then go back to Wuhan the next day
Katrina: 没有开始呢
Katrina: It hasn't even started
Katrina: 都没分手
Katrina: We haven't even broken up
Katrina: 那伤那么重
Katrina: And it hurts so much
Katrina: 只是觉得他很奇怪
Katrina: I just think he's really strange
Katrina: 搞不懂这男的也想什么
Katrina: Can't figure out what this guy is thinking
Katrina: 会不会是因为他是土相星座呀
Katrina: Could it be because he's an Earth sign?
Nicous: 干什么
Nicous: What
Shure: 我也是土相
Shure: I'm an Earth sign too
Nicous: 干什么
Nicous: What
Katrina: 你也是土相
Katrina: You're an Earth sign too
Nicous: 你是水像
Nicous: You're a Water sign
Katrina: 我我
Katrina: I, I
Katrina: 我他
Katrina: I, he
Katrina: 我是火相
Katrina: I'm a Fire sign
Shure: 我先是那个
Shure: First, I need to...
Nicous: 火像是什么座
Nicous: Fire signs are which ones?
Katrina: 射手
Katrina: Sagittarius.
Shure: 轰轰烈烈
Shure: Bold and grand.
Nicous: 我是我但我一点都不知道
Nicous: That's me but I know nothing about it.
Katrina: 你不像你不像
Katrina: You don't seem like it.
Katrina: 你是什么
Katrina: What's your sign?
Shure: 我是土相
Shure: I'm an Earth sign.
Katrina: 我最讨厌
Katrina: I hate that.
Katrina: 你们土相
Katrina: You Earth signs.
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's wrong?
Shure: 我们土相怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with us Earth signs?
Katrina: 土相土相
Katrina: Earth signs, Earth signs.
Katrina: 琢磨不明白
Katrina: Can't figure it out.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure: 土相就一根筋
Shure: Earth signs are just stubborn.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 他好琢磨的
Shure: They're hard to figure out.
Shure: 土相就是那种
Shure: Earth signs are like that.
Nicous: 多去看看抖音
Nicous: Check out TikTok more.
Shure: 问你在干嘛就代表喜欢你的那种
Shure: If they ask what you're doing, it means they like you.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Katrina: 呃但是不是
Katrina: Uh, but not really.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Katrina: 我是做过攻略的
Katrina: I've done my research.
Shure: 是我说的对吧
Shure: Am I right?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What are you talking about?
Katrina: 但是那个是同时发生的
Katrina: But it happened at the same time.
Jake:一脸蒙逼
Jake: I'm so confused.
Katrina: 你怎么解释呢
Katrina: How do you explain it?
Shure: 你猜
Shure: You guess.
Jake:我猜啊
Jake: I guess?
Jake:你们很懂吗
Jake: Do you really know?
Katrina: 上网查一下杨婧康
Katrina: Look it up, Yang Jingkang.
Jake:你们很懂吗
Jake: Do you really know?
Shure: 我们很懂
Shure: We know.
Katrina: 很懂
Katrina: We know.
Shure: 非常懂
Shure: We know very well.
Jake:非常懂
Jake: Very well.
Jake:那那那猜一下
Jake: Then, then guess.
Katrina: 但
Katrina: But
Jake:哪里懂得什么
Jake: How would you even know?
Katrina: 就是知道了你座以后才能大概猜一下你性格
Katrina: You can kind of guess your personality after knowing your zodiac sign.
Katrina: 倒不能从性格的推出性
Katrina: But you can't deduce personality from the sign.
Jake:哦不能反对是吧
Jake: Oh, you can't reverse it, right?
Jake:不能反推是吧对
Jake: You can't deduce it backwards, right?
Katrina: 特别像奶奶啊在这
Katrina: You really remind me of my grandma here.
Katrina: 上网百度一下杨靖康吧
Katrina: Let's search Yang Jingkang online.
Katrina: 看那guitar上会不会放他的东西啊guitar
Katrina: See if there's anything about him on guitar, guitar.
Jake:guitar可能没放这些东西
Jake: Guitar probably doesn't have that stuff.
Shure: 那上那上另一个HAP上找找去哈哈哈
Shure: Then try searching on another HAP, haha.
Jake:天秤秤
Jake: Libra, Libra.
Jake:十月份差不多
Jake: Around October.
Shure: 天秤座也很
Shure: Libras are also very...
Katrina: 前男友天秤座
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend was a Libra.
Shure: 天秤座是什么
Shure: What are Libras like?
Katrina: 风相的
Katrina: They're air signs.
Shure: 他是风相
Shure: He's an air sign?
Katrina: 他不像
Katrina: He doesn't seem like one.
Shure: 不对啊
Shure: That's not right.
Jake:十月份差不多
Jake: Around October.
Shure: 所以这个
Shure: So this...
Katrina: 可能我没有看到他的另 一面
Katrina: Maybe I haven't seen his other side.
Katrina: 只看到他工作的一面
Katrina: I've only seen his work side.
Jake:风相应该是什么样
Jake: What's an air sign supposed to be like?
Shure: 风相就是
Shure: Air signs are...
Katrina: 蛮疯的
Katrina: Pretty wild.
Shure: 蛮疯的对
Shure: Pretty wild, yeah.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 对就是每天都是
Shure: Yeah, like every day they're...
Shure: 还想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: They want to talk to you about the universe and the sky.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 或是沙滩里的碎石和人生
Shure: Or the pebbles on the beach and life.
Shure: 哦就是这个样子的一个人
Shure: Oh, just that kind of person.
Shure: 然后呢这是第几次
Shure: So, how many times has it been?
Katrina: 整不明白
Katrina: I can't figure it out.
Katrina: 说什么这个吗嗯
Katrina: Are you talking about this? Hmm.
Shure: 我想快压一次
Shure: I want to press it quickly.
Katrina: 但是我去这么厚这个能压吗
Katrina: But this is so thick, can it be pressed?
Shure: 我就想把它就是这个垮给还原出来
Shure: I just want to restore it back to how it was.
Shure: 你懂吗
Shure: Do you understand?
Katrina: 但是应该要把这拔一下
Katrina: But we need to pull this out.
Katrina: 反正这太硬了它压不下去
Katrina: Anyway, this is too hard, it won't press down.
Shure: 那你怎么操作
Shure: So how do you operate it?
Katrina: 就这样拔吧
Katrina: Just pull it like this.
Katrina: 拔然后把它剪短
Katrina: Pull it out and then cut it short.
Shure: 那你要把它拔坏了怎么办
Shure: What if you pull it out and break it?
Katrina: 坏了就坏了呗
Katrina: If it breaks, it breaks.
Shure: 坏了我在这哭
Shure: If it breaks, I'll cry here.
Katrina: 哭吧给你一大嘴巴子
Katrina: Cry then, I'll give you a big slap.
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这个样子
Shure: Haha, why are you like this?
Katrina: 这老师可不温柔
Katrina: This teacher isn't gentle at all.
Katrina: 但是我妈让我学师范
Katrina: But my mom wants me to study education.
Katrina: 我说你觉得我能学师范
Katrina: I said, do you think I can study education?
Katrina: 我打小孩
Katrina: I hit kids.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 棍棒底下出孝子
Shure: Strict teachers produce excellent students.
Shure: 严师出高徒
Shure: Strict teachers produce great disciples.
Katrina: 哇这个大花瓣
Katrina: Wow, look at this big petal.
Shure: 这个话不无道理
Shure: There's some truth to that.
Shure: 你给他拆了
Shure: You dismantled it.
Katrina: 不小心掉出一片
Katrina: A piece accidentally fell out.
Shure: 我就想让他整一个这样子
Shure: I just wanted him to make one like this.
Katrina: 整一个这个压不了啊
Katrina: Making one like this won't press down.
Katrina: 除非你一天到晚用屁股坐着他才能压
Katrina: Unless you sit on it all day, then it will press down.
Shure: 可以
Shure: That's fine.
Katrina: 蛮敬业的哟
Katrina: Quite dedicated, huh?
Lucia:那咱每次吃饭的时候就坐在上面
Lucia: Then we'll sit on it every time we eat.
Katrina: 能长痔疮
Katrina: That could cause hemorrhoids.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Lucia:这样能让他干的就是
Lucia: This way, it can dry and be more even.
Lucia:说更平一点
Lucia: Just make it flatter.
Lucia:只要接触空调就会缩水
Lucia: As long as it touches the air conditioner, it will shrink.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈那应该不至于
Shure: Hahaha, that shouldn't happen.
Lucia:哇你的窗帘是吧
Lucia: Wow, is that your curtain?
Shure: 这就是充满爱意和
Shure: It's full of love and...
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我没有爱意
Katrina: I have no love.
Lucia:这个是雨轩的吗
Lucia: Is this Yuxuan's?
Katrina: 啊这是我的
Katrina: Ah, it's mine.
Katrina: 我买的香薰
Katrina: I bought an incense diffuser.
Lucia:是那种蜡烛式的吗
Lucia: Is it the candle type?
Katrina: 不是无香的
Katrina: No, it’s unscented.
Katrina: 他毕竟有扩扩香器
Katrina: It does have a diffuser though.
Lucia:好好看等你拆了记得叫我观摩一下
Lucia: Looks nice. Remember to call me when you unbox it.
Katrina: 好好我现在拆
Katrina: Sure, I’ll unbox it now.
Lucia:其实我今天打开了这个盒子
Lucia: Actually, I opened this box today.
Lucia:发现里面还有一层盒子
Lucia: Found another box inside.
Lucia:你没有拆过
Lucia: You haven't opened it before?
Katrina: 我看看
Katrina: Let me see.
Lucia:我就决定先留着让你拆
Lucia: I decided to save it for you to open.
Katrina: 我也不知道长啥样呢
Katrina: I don’t even know what it looks like.
Katrina: 万一跟那个实物不符
Katrina: What if it doesn't match the picture?
Jake:走看狗去
Jake: Let’s go see the dog.
Jake:可以了吧
Jake: Is it ready?
Lucia:耶
Lucia: Yay!
Lucia:i'm ready now
Lucia: I'm ready now.
Jake:狗狗
Jake: Doggy.
Lucia:哦好看
Lucia: Oh, it looks good.
Jake:快去
Jake: Go quickly.
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who's there?
Jake:还有还有人呢
Jake: There are more people.
Katrina: 她
Katrina: Her.
Jake:克星呢
Jake: The nemesis.
Katrina: 全体吗
Katrina: Everyone?
Lucia:都可以
Lucia: Anyone is fine.
Katrina: 穿睡衣应该没问题
Katrina: Wearing pajamas should be okay.
Lucia:这是一个自由选择的副本
Lucia: This is an optional quest.
Katrina: 反正就200米
Katrina: Anyway, it's just 200 meters.
Katrina: 跟遛弯一样
Katrina: Like taking a walk.
Jake:对就是遛弯
Jake: Yeah, just a walk.
Jake:我我我压花
Jake: I, I, I’m pressing flowers.
Shure: 然后一直坐着他
Shure: Then just sit on it.
Katrina: 行啊
Katrina: Fine.
Jake:那个能孵出糖花来
Jake: That can produce sugar flowers.
Katrina: 冰糖来一颗不
Katrina: Want a piece of rock candy?
Lucia:这压花的意思其实是压在花上是吧
Lucia: So pressing flowers means pressing on flowers, right?
Katrina: 冰糖
Katrina: Rock candy.
Shure: 纯吗这个
Shure: Is it pure?
Tasha:盐呢盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt, where's the salt?
Katrina: 盐做的
Katrina: Made with salt.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Jake:走走走咿呀走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Lucia:好好看
Lucia: Looks great.
Katrina: 对我要做一下我的手工任务
Katrina: Yeah, I need to work on my craft project.
Katrina: 火很重的
Katrina: The fire is really strong.
Shure: 我怎怎么怎么弄
Shure: How do I, how do I do this?
Shure: 下一步老师老师
Shure: Next step, teacher, teacher.
Katrina: 等一下老师忙副线任务去了
Katrina: Wait a second, the teacher is busy with a side quest.
Katrina: 你可以告诉我怎么做
Katrina: Can you tell me how to do it?
Shure: 然后我自己弄
Shure: Then I'll do it myself.
Tasha:昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did we use salt yesterday?
Katrina: 我也不太知道
Katrina: I'm not sure either.
Tasha:昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did we use salt yesterday?
Katrina: 昨天吗
Katrina: Yesterday?
Shure: 昨天好像没怎么用盐
Shure: I don't think we used much salt yesterday.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 唉呀妈呀唉呀妈呀
Katrina: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Shure: 哦如果我想把它压成花的样
Shure: Oh, if I want to press it into a flower shape,
Shure: 我要让他屁股冲上是吗
Shure: I need to have its bottom facing up, right?
Shure: 嗯然后他的屁股冲上
Shure: Yeah, with its bottom facing up.
Lucia:渴了
Lucia: I'm thirsty.
Katrina: 然后这种的话我看人家都是侧着压的
Katrina: And for this, I see people press it sideways.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Katrina: 随便你自己发挥吧
Katrina: Do it however you like.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Katrina: 盐
Katrina: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Shure: OK那就这样
Shure: OK, let's do it this way.
Shure: 老师摆的很好
Shure: The teacher arranged it well.
Shure: 然后下一步应该给他盖上盖
Shure: Then the next step should be to cover it.
Katrina: 那就
Katrina: Then...
Tasha:不可能呀
Tasha: No way.
Katrina: 压个两层吧
Katrina: Press it into two layers.
Lucia:没桃了还有可能没盐应该不至于吧
Lucia: We might be out of peaches, but we shouldn't be out of salt, right?
Shure: 再加一层盐呢
Shure: Add another layer of salt?
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 直接给他上两层干燥吧
Katrina: Just give it two layers of drying.
Katrina: 感觉这个有点难度呀
Katrina: This seems a bit tricky.
Jake:应该都在这吧
Jake: Everything should be here, right?
Lucia:是不是昨天烧烤的时候拿出去用过
Lucia: Did we use it during the barbecue yesterday?
Lucia:但是那也应该拿回来了吧
Lucia: But it should have been brought back, right?
Katrina: 有点可忘记了
Katrina: I kind of forgot.
Katrina: 这中间要不要在加一层
Katrina: Should we add another layer in the middle?
Lucia:我们有勺了
Lucia: We have a spoon.
Jake:对买勺了
Jake: Yeah, we bought a spoon.
Jake:盐没盐了怎么办
Jake: What do we do if we run out of salt?
Lucia:我先在这组装
Lucia: I'll assemble it here first.
Lucia:一会出发了叫我
Lucia: Call me when we're leaving.
Lucia:说明书上哪了在这
Lucia: Where's the manual? Oh, here it is.
Lucia:啊这玩意装完了我还得给他
Lucia: Ah, after assembling this, I still have to...
Lucia:到时候再拆一次
Lucia: Take it apart again later.
Lucia:真麻烦
Lucia: So troublesome.
Lucia:咕咕咕咕咕
Lucia: Gurgle, gurgle, gurgle.
Katrina: 我草做错了
Katrina: Oh no, I did it wrong.
Lucia:我用一下底下这个东西
Lucia: I'm going to use this thing below.
Katrina: 错了老师
Katrina: Wrong, teacher.
Katrina: 谁呀给我打电话
Katrina: Who's calling me?
Katrina: 老师喂
Katrina: Hello, teacher?
Katrina: 嗯你哪位
Katrina: Uh, who is this?
Katrina: 不方便拜拜
Katrina: Not convenient, bye.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:不要了
Tasha: Don't need it.
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina: 美团
Katrina: Meituan.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's wrong?
Katrina: 我不知道他说什么
Katrina: I don't know what he said.
Katrina: 社区客服小盐他问我方不方便
Katrina: Community service, Xiao Yan, he asked if I was available.
Shure: 那就是AI的
Shure: That's AI.
Katrina: 我说不方便
Katrina: I said not convenient.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 我觉得我刚看教程说这上面还要粘一层
Katrina: I think the tutorial said to stick another layer on top.
Tasha:看狗半个小时
Tasha: Watch the dog for half an hour.
Jake:好半小时绰绰有余
Jake: Half an hour is more than enough.
Tasha:10分钟
Tasha: 10 minutes.
Jake:多久啊一般
Jake: How long usually?
Katrina: 要搞两层卧槽上午做错了
Katrina: Need two layers, damn it, did it wrong this morning.
Jake:狗能看个10分钟吗
Jake: Can the dog watch for 10 minutes?
Katrina: 上午忘加另一层
Katrina: I forgot to add another layer this morning.
Jake:走
Jake: Let’s go.
Jake:走吧出发
Jake: Come on, let’s head out.
Tasha:你不去是吗
Tasha: You’re not coming, right?
Shure: 我不去
Shure: I’m not.
Tasha:你能在4:32的时候把火给关掉吗
Tasha: Can you turn off the heat at 4:32?
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 定个闹钟
Katrina: Set an alarm.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 帮我定个4:32闹钟
Shure: Set a 4:32 alarm for me.
Lucia:哎准备走了好吧
Lucia: Hey, get ready to go.
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let’s go, let’s go.
Lucia:等我回来再接着安排
Lucia: I’ll handle the rest when I get back.
Katrina: 应该是这样
Katrina: That should be it.
Lucia:呃呃you can get here and
Lucia: Uh, you can get here and...
Lucia:我怎么觉得还有一个2
Lucia: Why do I feel like there’s another 2?
Katrina: 应该是
Katrina: Probably.
Lucia:不管了先这样吧
Lucia: Never mind, let’s leave it.
Katrina: 没关系
Katrina: It’s fine.
Katrina: 可以跟你讲了
Katrina: I can tell you now.
Katrina: 为什么就是就是
Katrina: Why, it’s just...
Katrina: 我跟你讲我们是怎么认识的
Katrina: Let me tell you how we met.
Katrina: 感觉特别丢人
Katrina: It’s kinda embarrassing.
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: So, it was...
Katrina: 当时夏令营保研的时候
Katrina: During the summer camp for grad school.
Katrina: 我不是去面东南吗
Katrina: I was going to interview at Southeast.
Katrina: 然后我是早上
Katrina: And I was in the third batch in the morning.
Katrina: 第三批他是早上第一批
Katrina: He was in the first batch.
Katrina: 然后呢他就我就到了很早
Katrina: So I got there really early.
Katrina: 他就他也到了很早他就搓了一下我
Katrina: He also got there really early and tapped me.
Katrina: 问我就是同学第一批进去要不要带u盘
Katrina: He asked if the first batch needed to bring a USB drive.
Katrina: 然后我就就那样跟他见第一面
Katrina: And that was our first meeting.
Katrina: 但是就是只看他上半张脸
Katrina: But I only saw the top half of his face.
Katrina: 不知道他长啥样你知道吗
Katrina: I didn’t know what he looked like.
Katrina: 再也没有好的说话
Katrina: We didn’t talk much after that.
Katrina: 然后呢后来冬暖结束以后
Katrina: Then, after the camp ended,
Katrina: 马上又收到了
Katrina: I got a call from Beijing Normal University.
Katrina: 北师吃的那个录音通知
Katrina: About an interview.
Katrina: 然后我就来北京
Katrina: So I went to Beijing.
Katrina: 来北京的时候在吃饭的时候
Katrina: And while having a meal there...
Katrina: 他认出我来了
Katrina: He recognized me.
Katrina: 就是我们俩又参加了同一个夏令营
Katrina: We both attended the same summer camp again.
Katrina: 他就问我说
Katrina: He asked me,
Katrina: 同学
Katrina: "Classmate,
Katrina: 你是不是参加过东南大学计算机夏令营
Katrina: did you attend the computer summer camp at Southeast University?"
Katrina: 我说对啊
Katrina: I said, "Yeah."
Katrina: 然后我说你哪位
Katrina: Then I asked, "Who are you?"
Katrina: 然后看一下我就我就认出他俩了
Katrina: And then I looked at him and recognized him.
Katrina: 然后这就是我俩认识经过啊
Katrina: That's how we met.
Katrina: 然后他
Katrina: Then he...
Katrina: 但是那个时候还是有男朋友
Katrina: But at that time, I had a boyfriend.
Katrina: 后来才分手的
Katrina: We broke up later.
Katrina: 后来分手以后
Katrina: After we broke up,
Katrina: 没有那时候只是当普通朋友啦
Katrina: we were just regular friends back then.
Katrina: 那时候没啥感觉
Katrina: I didn't feel anything at that time.
Katrina: 那时候就觉得
Katrina: I just thought...
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 你问问你自己是那么想的吗
Shure: Are you sure you really felt that way?
Katrina: 没有那种感觉
Katrina: I didn't feel that way.
Katrina: 当时有男朋友谈那么久吗
Katrina: I had a boyfriend for a long time back then.
Katrina: 压吧
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How is it?
Katrina: 这个就直接把它放上去不能让它
Katrina: Just put it directly up there, don't let it...
Katrina: 然后后来就是嗯
Katrina: Then later, um...
Katrina: 我分手那时间9月份还预推免的
Katrina: I broke up in September, during the pre-recommendation period.
Katrina: 然后就学不进去啊啥的然后
Katrina: Then I couldn't focus on studying, and...
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Katrina: 我们就就一直聊天哈哈哈
Katrina: We just kept chatting, hahaha.
Shure: 不是你先把这个给我解决吧
Shure: No, solve this for me first.
Katrina: 然后呢然后就直接上木板子就行
Katrina: Then, just put it directly on the wooden board.
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Katrina: 上木板
Katrina: Put it on the wooden board.
Katrina: 上木板都都麻得他那样行弄两根
Katrina: Put it on the wooden board, like that, use two pieces.
Katrina: 噫
Katrina: Yikes.
Katrina: 那两根呢
Katrina: Where are the two pieces?
Katrina: 绑带呢
Katrina: Where's the strap?
Katrina: 啊卧槽
Katrina: Oh crap.
Katrina: 怎么在地上
Katrina: How did it end up on the floor?
Katrina: 有点乱了
Shure: 哇好色情这个绑带
Katrina: 人家讲起来很费劲啊
Katrina: 我就是一直搞不明白这个男的
Katrina: 他怎么想的
Katrina: 因为他之前
Shure: 你可以告诉我
Katrina: 我觉得是他先
Shure: 他的名字
Katrina: 不行
Shure: 我万一真认识呢
Shure: 我跟你我认
Shure: 如果认识这个人
Shure: 我就可以跟你进一步分析
Katrina: 真的
Shure: 是的
Katrina: 叫叫叫叫
Katrina: 应该不认识吧
Shure:  不认识
Shure: I don't know him.
Katrina: 这个太好了
Katrina: This is great.
Katrina: 嗯，这油好臭
Katrina: Hmm, this oil smells terrible.
Shure: 我们的小小小周
Shure: Our little Zhou.
Katrina: 小周呢就是他先说了一些很越界
Katrina: Little Zhou said some really inappropriate things.
Katrina: 就是包括他还有一些小名啊啥的
Katrina: Including some nicknames and stuff.
Katrina: 那日分手还包括
Katrina: The day they broke up, he even...
Shure: 小摩尔
Shure: Little Mo'er.
Katrina: 小明
Katrina: Little Ming.
Shure: 管你叫轩老师
Shure: He called you Teacher Xuan.
Katrina: 没有刚开始可是叫轩轩轩轩
Katrina: At first, he just kept calling Xuan Xuan Xuan.
Katrina: 天天这样的喊
Katrina: He called like that every day.
Katrina: 只有我家的长辈才这样喊
Katrina: Only my elders call me that way.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then...
Shure: 见女生面直接叫叠词
Shure: He calls girls by repeating their names.
Katrina: 后来聊的比较多
Katrina: Later, we talked more.
Katrina: 就是感觉两个人三观比较相符
Katrina: We felt our views were pretty similar.
Lucia:好多人他都闻不过来了
Lucia: He couldn't handle all the people.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 就聊的特别来包括还有一些很巧很巧的事
Katrina: We had such a great chat, and there were so many coincidences.
Katrina: 嗯就我们俩
Katrina: Yeah, just the two of us.
Katrina: 我之前高中听了一个
Katrina: Back in high school, I listened to this one song.
Katrina: 当时高中听沈雨辰的时候
Katrina: When I was in high school listening to Shen Yuchen,
Katrina: 沈雨辰还没火呢
Katrina: Shen Yuchen wasn't famous yet.
Katrina: 还是在抖音上只发自己那个
Katrina: He was just posting his stuff on Douyin.
Katrina: 后来他大学的时候慢慢火了
Katrina: Later, he gradually became famous in college.
Katrina: 然后去参加音乐节唱
Katrina: Then he started singing at music festivals.
Katrina: 然后当时有一次
Katrina: And once,
Katrina: 我前男友不是10天后来找我吗
Katrina: my ex-boyfriend came to see me after 10 days, right?
Katrina: 那一次我靠就是明明想通
Katrina: That time, I was like, even though I had figured things out,
Katrina: 但是心情还是巨难受
Katrina: I was still feeling really down.
Katrina: 然后我室友都去图书馆了
Katrina: My roommates had all gone to the library,
Katrina: 我就特别想找一个人吐槽说话
Katrina: and I just really wanted to talk to someone.
Katrina: 然后给打电话
Katrina: So I made a call.
Katrina: 我打电话
Katrina: I called him.
Katrina: 我发现他铃声就是那一首
Katrina: And I realized his ringtone was that song.
Katrina: 我之前听了很久很久的歌
Katrina: The one I had been listening to for ages.
Katrina: 然后他还跟我说
Katrina: Then he told me
Katrina: 他的大一就也听了很久很久的事情
Katrina: he'd also been listening to it for a long time during his freshman year.
Katrina: 然后后来包括我们俩那个年度
Katrina: Later on, even our annual playlists had several songs in common.
Katrina: 年度歌单都有好几首重的
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: there was also,
Katrina: 然后还有那个叫
Katrina: what's it called...
Katrina: 叫叫什么
Katrina: What's it called...
Katrina: 就我之前老想买一个牌子衣服
Katrina: I had always wanted to buy clothes from this brand.
Katrina: 就那holister嘛
Katrina: Hollister, right?
Katrina: 然后身边没有人穿
Katrina: But no one around me wore it.
Katrina: 他穿还有一个男生竟然穿
Katrina: He wore it, and another guy wore it too.
Shure: 那是什么衣服
Shure: What kind of clothes are those?
Katrina: 就是一个美国的一个快销品牌holister
Katrina: It's an American fast fashion brand, Hollister.
Katrina: 就是比较适合我的身材
Katrina: It fits my body type well.
Katrina: 我就经常买他们家的衣服
Katrina: I often buy their clothes.
Katrina: 然后呢反正就聊得特别来吧
Katrina: So anyway, we just had great conversations.
Katrina: 然后我们俩
Katrina: And the two of us,
Katrina: 我当时
Katrina: at that time,
Katrina: 当时后来面北航的时候是9月底
Katrina: when I was interviewing at Beihang University in late September,
Katrina: 然后那个时候我们俩已经聊得比较熟了吗一分手
Katrina: we had already become quite familiar with each other, and after a breakup,
Katrina: 我靠那次来北京全程接送啊
Katrina: he took care of me the whole time I was in Beijing.
Katrina: 就是当时
Katrina: At that time...
Katrina: 嗯面的心情有点糟糕
Katrina: My mood was a bit down.
Katrina: 因为全程道歉
Katrina: Because I had to apologize the whole time.
Katrina: 然后他就带我去吃火锅啥的
Katrina: Then he took me out for hot pot and stuff.
Katrina: 就是你知道我前男友
Katrina: You know my ex-boyfriend.
Katrina: 我跟他出去玩啥的
Katrina: When we went out,
Katrina: 是需要我做攻略和安排
Katrina: I had to plan everything.
Katrina: 那吃饭的地你知道吗
Katrina: You know the restaurants and all.
Katrina: 然后就感觉就被被人照顾那种
Katrina: It felt like I was being taken care of.
Katrina: 哎反正就是嗯
Katrina: Anyway, um.
Katrina: 还有那个什么
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 就那个
Katrina: you know,
Katrina: 就10月底的时候去了一次南昌音乐节
Katrina: at the end of October, I went to a music festival in Nanchang.
Katrina: 音乐节不看陶喆吗那时候
Katrina: The one with David Tao, remember?
Katrina: 然后呢那一次出去玩的时候
Katrina: So, that time when we went out,
Katrina: 就跟他去的
Katrina: we went together.
Katrina: 对跟他去了以后
Katrina: Yeah, after we went together,
Katrina: 我就觉得
Katrina: I felt that
Katrina: 他对我就是那种
Katrina: he was treating me like...
Katrina: 非常非常照顾的那种感觉
Katrina: 然后我就感觉我应该是11月多的时候
Katrina: And then I felt like it was around November.
Katrina: 确定自己应该是有点喜欢他
Katrina: I realized I might have a bit of a crush on him.
Katrina: 但是就是那次之后
Katrina: But then after that time,
Katrina: 感觉他有点乎冷乎热的
Katrina: He started acting kind of hot and cold.
Katrina: 然后就觉得很怪哎
Katrina: And it felt really weird.
Katrina: 影响到我的心情以后
Katrina: It affected my mood a lot.
Katrina: 我后来就有点搓破了
Katrina: Then I kind of messed things up.
Katrina: 就是我感觉可能
Katrina: I mean, I felt like maybe
Katrina: 不该那么早的搓破
Katrina: I shouldn't have messed things up so early.
Katrina: 后来就变得有点尴尬
Katrina: Things got awkward afterwards.
Katrina: 然后话就越来越少
Katrina: And we started talking less and less.
Katrina: 然后12月的时候我又来北京
Katrina: Then in December, I came to Beijing again.
Katrina: 是因为我很想知道他到底是什么意思
Katrina: Because I really wanted to know what he meant.
Katrina: 但是我没敢问你知道吗
Katrina: But I didn't dare to ask, you know?
Katrina: 然后又来北京的时候
Katrina: And then when I came to Beijing again,
Katrina: 他第二天直接不跟我说话了
Katrina: The next day, he just stopped talking to me.
Katrina: 然后哎呦
Katrina: And, oh my gosh,
Katrina: 我现在觉得他这人好那个呀
Katrina: Now I think he’s really something.
Katrina: 然后就
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 就本来是属于那种
Katrina: It was originally supposed to be like...
Katrina: 几个月每天都在聊天的那种
Katrina: We were chatting every day for a few months.
Katrina: 就那种断崖式暧昧一样你知道吗
Katrina: It was like a cliffhanger kind of flirting, you know?
Katrina: 就他那天叫什么突然不找你了
Katrina: Like, he suddenly stopped contacting you one day.
Katrina: 那我也不找他了什么的
Katrina: So I stopped reaching out to him too.
Katrina: 然后就
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 就这样一个多月就没有说话过了
Katrina: We didn't talk for over a month.
Katrina: 然后本来又是网友就不说话
Katrina: And since we were just online friends, we just stopped talking.
Katrina: 就是再也没有联系的那种你知道吗
Katrina: Like, we never contacted each other again, you know?
Katrina: 然后然后就
Katrina: And then, and then...
Katrina: 然后后来我还是12月底的时候
Katrina: Later, around the end of December...
Katrina: 我前男友不就考完研了吗
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend finished his exams.
Katrina: 就开始给我发消息那种
Katrina: And he started messaging me.
Katrina: 然后呢我当时可烦了
Katrina: At that time, I was really annoyed.
Katrina: 然后:然后北邮男的现在我们我们都叫他北邮男的
Katrina: And then, we called him the "Beiyou guy."
Katrina: 一骂就是骂整体北邮男的
Katrina: We cursed all Beiyou guys.
Katrina: 然后然后他当时
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 他当时也是对我那种忽冷忽热
Katrina: At that time, he was also hot and cold with me.
Katrina: 就是你会有的时候会觉得很有希望
Katrina: Sometimes, I felt really hopeful.
Katrina: 就是他跟你说的那些话的时候
Katrina: When he said certain things to me.
Jake:他还知道跑过去
Jake: He even knew to come over.
Katrina: 那有的时候
Katrina: But sometimes...
Katrina: 但是你又能明显的感觉到
Katrina: You could clearly feel...
Katrina: 这三个月内有很大的落差感
Katrina: There was a huge gap in those three months.
Katrina: 哦然后呢
Katrina: Oh, and then...
Katrina: 嗯我我生日的后一天
Katrina: The day after my birthday...
Katrina: 然后我发现他把我生日给忘了
Katrina: I realized he forgot my birthday.
Katrina: 就12月21那天
Katrina: It was December 21st.
Katrina: 然后12月22的时候
Katrina: Then on December 22nd...
Katrina: 12月12月22的时候我
Katrina: On December 22nd...
Katrina: 12月22的时候我前男友又给我发短信
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend texted me again.
Katrina: 我就跟我前男友说他说直接断了
Katrina: I told him to cut it off directly.
Katrina: 不要再给我发任何短信
Katrina: Stop texting me.
Katrina: 就是影响我心情
Katrina: It's affecting my mood.
Katrina: 然后顺便把北邮男友也给斩了
Katrina: And I also cut off the Beiyou guy.
Katrina: 就我直接给人家戳明白了
Katrina: I made it clear to him.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我就直接跟他说
Katrina: I told him directly.
Katrina: 他之前的一些言语和行为
Katrina: His previous words and actions...
Katrina: 就是让我会有那种想法
Katrina: Made me think we were having a thing.
Katrina: 就我以为我们俩是在暧昧的
Katrina: I thought we were in a flirtation.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 然后啊他那边的意思
Katrina: And then, what he meant was...
Katrina: 就是普通朋友
Katrina: ...just regular friends.
Katrina: 哈哈哈啊
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 是吧然后我说啊
Katrina: Right? So I said...
Katrina: 人家普通朋友这样相处的呀
Katrina: Do regular friends interact like this?
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Like...
Katrina: 我靠就是高铁上那个时候
Katrina: On the high-speed train, I fell asleep on his shoulder.
Katrina: 嗯我睡着了就靠他肩上
Katrina: Do regular people interact like this?
Katrina: 就普通人是这样相处的
Katrina: At that time, I thought it was ambiguous, you know?
Katrina: 那时候我以为是暧昧你知道吗
Katrina: But later...
Katrina: 然后就后来
Katrina: Later on...
Katrina: 他后来我觉得怪的一个点就是
Katrina: I thought it was weird because...
Katrina: 他在中途的时候
Katrina: In the middle of it...
Katrina: 比如说我说我们计算机来了一个那个
Katrina: For example, I said our computer department got a new...
Katrina: 那个他学弟还长得挺帅的
Katrina: ...a new guy, and he's quite handsome.
Katrina: 他跟我说那你去加微信啊
Katrina: And he told me to add him on WeChat.
Katrina: 然后我想的是
Katrina: And I thought...
Katrina: 暧昧对象
Katrina: An ambiguous relationship...
Katrina: 就是会让你去加别人的微信吗
Katrina: ...would let you add someone else on WeChat?
Katrina: 就是他一直只把你当普通朋友那种吗
Katrina: So he always just saw you as a regular friend?
Katrina: 然
Katrina: And...
Katrina: 他这人挺怪的你知道吗
Katrina: He's pretty weird, you know?
Katrina: 然后他后来一直没找我以后
Katrina: And then he never contacted me again.
Katrina: 我甚至觉得他可能去找前女友了
Katrina: I even thought he might have gone back to his ex.
Katrina: 就是一种第六感你知道吗
Katrina: It's like a sixth sense, you know?
Katrina: 然后然后我就那天跟他斩断
Katrina: So then, that day, I cut him off.
Katrina: 我说以后不要再给我发任何消息
Katrina: I told him not to message me anymore.
Katrina: 我们俩就这样断了
Katrina: And we ended it.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: Then...
Katrina: 然后跨年的时候就跟人家说新年快乐
Katrina: On New Year's, he still wished me a Happy New Year.
Shure: 真的真的太丢脸了
Shure: Seriously, that's so embarrassing.
Shure: 你怎么就可一棵树吊死
Shure: Why would you get hung up on one person like that?
Katrina: 这太丢人了
Katrina: It's so embarrassing.
Katrina: 我就因为我就是那种
Katrina: It's just that I'm the kind of person...
Katrina: 我是属于那种非常非常典型的火相
Katrina: I'm the typical fiery type.
Katrina: 就是不在乎那种什么面子不面子
Katrina: I don't care about face or whatever.
Katrina: 我想说就说
Katrina: If I want to say something, I'll say it.
Katrina: 如果如果我当时憋着更难受的话
Katrina: If holding it in makes me feel worse...
Katrina: 我就会选择说就就是
Katrina: I'll choose to say it.
Katrina: 所有就全靠自己的心情办事
Katrina: I just do whatever I feel like doing.
Katrina: 然后呢后来就偶尔又断断续续聊了
Katrina: And then, we would occasionally chat on and off.
Katrina: 但是后来又觉得
Katrina: But later, I felt that
Katrina: 他有时候就正常的一个话题
Katrina: sometimes, during a normal conversation,
Katrina: 他可能就不接了
Katrina: he just wouldn't respond.
Katrina: 然后又这样断断了以后
Katrina: And after some breaks,
Katrina: 然后这次这次我是真没想到
Katrina: this time, I really didn't expect it.
Katrina: 来北京就是我
Katrina: Coming to Beijing,
Katrina: 我都已经做好心理建设
Katrina: I had already mentally prepared myself.
Katrina: 就是就
Katrina: That is, I
Katrina: 已经掰了呗
Katrina: had already decided to end it.
Katrina: 掰了也无所谓啊
Katrina: And it didn't matter if it ended.
Katrina: 然后然后又来了一趟北京
Katrina: Then, I came to Beijing again.
Katrina: 他那次脱口秀
Katrina: For his stand-up show.
Katrina: 因为当时那个富豪是我俩一起看的
Katrina: Because back then, that wealthy guy was someone we watched together.
Katrina: 然后就说约一下线下吧
Katrina: So, we decided to meet up offline.
Katrina: 嗯就来了
Katrina: And I came.
Katrina: 我当时以为话会很少
Katrina: I thought there would be very few words.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 因为他线上就跟我
Katrina: Because online, he barely talked to me.
Katrina: 就话特别特别少那种
Katrina: He was very, very quiet online.
Katrina: 然后呢他线下结果话巨多
Katrina: But offline, he talked a lot.
Katrina: 他一直在跟我说话
Katrina: He kept talking to me.
Katrina: 一直在跟我说
Katrina: Kept talking.
Katrina: 我刚开始觉得有点尴尬
Katrina: At first, I felt a bit awkward.
Katrina: 因为毕竟我这边单方面有点小九九
Katrina: Because I had some personal feelings.
Katrina: 然后他就一直在说嗯
Katrina: But he just kept talking.
Katrina: 他12月那个时候那个项目什么结了
Katrina: He said that his project ended in December.
Katrina: 哎呦开第二个什么的
Katrina: And he was starting a second one.
Katrina: 然后我就在想难不成真的是
Katrina: So, I thought, maybe he really was
Katrina: 这消失几个月全都在忙工作
Katrina: busy with work during those months.
Katrina: 就是他保北大去了
Katrina: He got into Peking University.
Katrina: 他保北大软薇
Katrina: Peking University Software, Tasha.
Katrina: 然后呢他没有进组
Katrina: But he didn't join a team.
Katrina: 但是他有一个自己的那种
Katrina: Instead, he had his own
Katrina: 类似于一种初创公司的那种项目吧
Katrina: kind of startup project.
Katrina: 就是做高中教辅那一块
Katrina: It was about high school tutoring.
Katrina: 然后就跟着
Katrina: Then, he
Katrina: 然后做一些自媒体的东西
Katrina: started doing some self-media stuff.
Katrina: 然后然后我觉得他哎真的是
Katrina: And then, I thought, maybe he really was
Katrina: 纯工作吗纯忙去了
Katrina: just busy with work the whole time.
Katrina: 然后这就是我来的目的
Katrina: And that's why I came.
Katrina: 就是我要去问清楚这件事情
Katrina: I need to figure this out.
Katrina: 就是啊不是说什么一定要
Katrina: I mean, it's not like it's a must or anything.
Katrina: 就是表明一下心意吧也不是什么非要在一起的那种
Katrina: Just want to express my feelings, it's not like we have to be together or something.
Katrina: 我觉得一定要问清楚为什么
Katrina: I think it's important to understand why.
Katrina: 当当时他到底是普通朋友
Katrina: Back then, was it just a normal friendship?
Katrina: 还是暧昧关系
Katrina: Or was it more like a romantic interest?
Katrina: 然后就断了的时候
Katrina: And when it ended,
Katrina: 就真的只在工作吗
Katrina: was it really just about work?
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 然后那次脱口秀那天回来以后
Katrina: after that stand-up comedy show,
Katrina: 就开始找我聊天
Katrina: he started chatting with me.
Katrina: 嗯找我找我说话
Katrina: Yeah, he came to talk to me.
Katrina: 然后最近没
Katrina: And recently,
Katrina: 这两天也有在聊天
Katrina: we've been chatting these past few days too.
Katrina: 哎有的时候呢
Katrina: Sometimes,
Katrina: 就突然跟我说一些爱情观的东西
Katrina: he suddenly talks to me about his views on love.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 那有的时候突然又来一句
Katrina: sometimes he suddenly says,
Katrina: 跟我说不想谈恋爱
Katrina: he doesn't want to be in a relationship.
Katrina: 我老天爷
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 然后当时有跟他讲
Katrina: At that time, I told him
Katrina: 我前男友那个2月份那个破事
Katrina: about the drama with my ex in February.
Katrina: 然后他就说哎呦谁跟你谈恋爱
Katrina: And he said, "Oh, whoever dates you,
Katrina: 真是幸福了
Katrina: must be so lucky."
Katrina: 然后然后我在哈哈哈哈什么意思
Katrina: And then I was like, "Hahaha, what do you mean?"
Katrina: 然后然后
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 然后刚刚又跟我说谈恋爱太麻烦了
Katrina: just now he told me again that relationships are too much trouble.
Katrina: 还是不谈比较好
Katrina: It's better not to date.
Katrina: 就觉得自己没有这种经历你知道吗
Katrina: I feel like I don't have that kind of experience, you know?
Katrina: 啊然后
Katrina: Ah, and then,
Katrina: 这哥们真有意思
Katrina: this guy is really something.
Katrina: 把我当狗耍的
Katrina: Treating me like a fool.
Katrina: 在这主要是我
Katrina: The main thing is, I...
Katrina: 我也是那种
Katrina: I am also the kind of person...
Katrina: 我也不是那种对所有人话都很多的
Katrina: I'm not someone who talks a lot to everyone.
Katrina: 好吧就是虽然说性格比较开朗
Katrina: Although I'm quite outgoing,
Katrina: 但是也也是那种
Katrina: but still,
Katrina: 也不是说对所有人都很多的那种
Katrina: I don't talk a lot to everyone.
Katrina: 我是这么想的
Katrina: That's what I think.
Jake:喜欢托鞋
Jake: Likes to wear slippers.
Katrina: 然后他刚跟我说哎
Katrina: And then he just told me, hey,
Katrina: 谈恋爱什么太麻烦了哦
Katrina: Dating is too troublesome.
Katrina: 不想谈恋爱
Katrina: I don't want to date.
Katrina: 那你他妈的昨天晚上问我在干嘛
Katrina: Then why the hell did you ask me what I was doing last night?
Katrina: 干嘛昨天晚上不是没回他消息吗
Katrina: Why didn't you reply to my messages last night?
Katrina: 上床呆了哦
Katrina: I was in bed.
Katrina: 然后他又问我你们在干嘛呀
Katrina: Then he asked me again, what were you doing?
Katrina: 关你屌事我请问
Katrina: None of your damn business, may I ask.
Katrina: 然后当时就去琢磨
Katrina: And then I thought about it.
Katrina: 人家MTI跟那个星座去了
Katrina: MTI and the zodiac signs.
Katrina: 所以我现在是懂懂王
Katrina: So now I am the understanding king.
Shure: 又觉得自己懂
Shure: And you think you understand.
Katrina: 摩羯
Katrina: Capricorn.
Shure: 我懂的
Shure: I understand.
Katrina: 摩羯INTJ
Katrina: Capricorn INTJ.
Katrina: 然后网上测了说我们俩相克
Katrina: Then online said we are incompatible.
Katrina: 哈哈哈测塔罗去了
Katrina: Haha, went to get tarot reading.
Katrina: 为你我用了所有的办法
Katrina: I tried everything for you.
Katrina: 还挺好看
Katrina: Quite good looking.
Shure: 哈哈我感觉吧他可能
Shure: Haha, I feel he might
Katrina: 你知道你知道那天还很奇怪是什么
Katrina: You know, you know what was weird that day?
Katrina: 就是呃我俩刚认识的时候
Katrina: When we first met,
Katrina: 他他之前前女友是那种高中带上来
Katrina: His ex-girlfriend was the kind that came from high school.
Katrina: 就是人大
Katrina: From Renmin University.
Katrina: 然后他就跟我说
Katrina: And then he told me
Katrina: 他跟他前女友的矛盾
Katrina: The conflicts with his ex
Katrina: 就是属于那种同城都不行
Katrina: Were because even in the same city, it didn't work.
Katrina: 他都接受不了
Katrina: He couldn't accept it.
Katrina: 同城就是要大家在一起谈恋爱那种
Katrina: Being in the same city means being together in a relationship.
Katrina: 然后呢那天看完脱口秀
Katrina: Then after watching a comedy show that day,
Katrina: 晚上回来跟我说
Katrina: He came back at night and told me
Katrina: 对其实我觉得异地恋比不异地好
Katrina: Actually, I think long-distance is better than not long-distance.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈对
Shure: Hahahahahaha, right.
Katrina: 这哥们
Katrina: This guy,
Katrina: 就当时
Katrina: At that time,
Katrina: 但是我现在已经就是波澜不惊了
Katrina: But now I am calm.
Katrina: 我不会像以前一样那么那么开心
Katrina: I won't be as happy as I was before, you know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 因为我知道他一下这样一下这样
Katrina: Because I know he is like this one moment and like that the next.
Katrina: 一下这样
Katrina: Just like this
Katrina: 然后我又无所谓了
Katrina: Then I was like, whatever
Katrina: 然后我这次过来
Katrina: And then this time when I came over
Katrina: 就是已经做好了99%被拒绝的准备
Katrina: I was already 99% prepared to be rejected
Katrina: 因为我想的是什么呢
Katrina: Because what I was thinking was
Katrina: 就是你当初那么就是难受的话
Katrina: If it was so uncomfortable back then
Katrina: 就是你一直要猜人家在说什么
Katrina: Always guessing what the other person was saying
Katrina: 你还不如直接表白然后被拒绝
Katrina: It’s better to just confess and get rejected
Katrina: 然后以后就再也不用跟他联系了
Katrina: Then you never have to contact him again
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 然后要倒是没想过
Katrina: I never even thought
Katrina: 如果成功会怎么样
Katrina: What if it actually worked out
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know
Katrina: 就是想的是绝对是那种失败的那种
Katrina: I was just thinking it would definitely fail
Katrina: 所以就是拭目以待吧
Katrina: So let’s just wait and see
Katrina: 然后我们当时就说
Katrina: And then we said
Katrina: 我靠北邮这学校再也不想来了
Katrina: 哈哈哈然后来了这个项目组才发现
Katrina: Haha, and then I joined this project group and realized
Katrina: 你们全是北邮的
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina: 然后当时就心里小小的破防了一下
Katrina: And then I felt a bit defeated
Katrina: 当时觉得
Katrina: At that moment
Shure: 感觉这两天
Shure: Feels like these two days
Katrina: 因为我一直叫他北邮男
Katrina: Because I always called him the guy from our school
Katrina: 北邮男你知道吗
Katrina: 然后我身边人
Katrina: And then everyone around me
Katrina: 所有人都觉得北邮男不是个好东西
Shure: 哈哈哈一棍子打死一片是吧
Shure: Haha, judging all of them by one
Katrina: 当时真没接触到第二个北邮男
Shure: 好现在你还多接触3个4个北邮男嗯
Katrina: 烤烤烤那个
Katrina: Bake, bake, bake that
Katrina: 他这个要烤暖
Katrina: It needs to be baked warm
Katrina: 然后等会要来搞蛋糕
Katrina: And then later we need to make the cake
Shure: 应该 是吧
Shure: Should be, right?
Katrina: 特别难受
Katrina: It’s really uncomfortable
Katrina: 这哥们搞不懂一点
Katrina: This guy doesn’t understand at all
Katrina: 就是感觉几个月没见面以后
Katrina: It’s like after not seeing each other for months
Katrina: 我也忙了一点自己的事情就可能
Katrina: I was also busy with my own stuff, so maybe
Katrina: 然后那天就是不知道怎么聊到了
Katrina: And then that day, I don’t know how we ended up talking
Katrina: 哦就是刚开始说
Katrina: Oh, at the beginning we said
Katrina: 聊到我说我几个月都没睡好了一个
Katrina: I told him I hadn't slept well for months.
Katrina: 要么就是那个前男友
Katrina: It's either because of my ex-boyfriend
Katrina: 当然把我气了一下
Katrina: who, of course, made me really mad.
Katrina: 气的作息不调
Katrina: So mad that my routine got messed up.
Katrina: 作息不调然后每次就到深夜就开始工作完了
Katrina: My routine got messed up, and I started working late at night.
Katrina: 哈哈哈就习惯这个
Katrina: Haha, I got used to it.
Katrina: 然后我就说他说你前男友什么事
Katrina: Then I told him, "What happened with your ex?"
Katrina: 我说我草你没看我朋友圈啊
Katrina: I was like, "Haven't you seen my posts?"
Katrina: 他就是好像就真没看
Katrina: And it seemed like he really hadn't seen them.
Katrina: 然后你给他讲
Katrina: So, I told him.
Katrina: 讲了以后
Katrina: After telling him,
Katrina: 就聊到一些这种爱情观的东西
Katrina: we started talking about views on love and relationships.
Katrina: 你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 然后他当时他就跟我说了一句
Katrina: Then he said to me,
Katrina: 我觉得你真的很不一样
Katrina: "I think you're really different."
Shure: 哈哈哈哎呦我草
Shure: Hahaha, oh my god.
Katrina: 哎呀我这什么意思
Katrina: I was like, "What does that mean?"
Shure: 好拙劣啊我感觉
Shure: That was so lame, I feel.
Katrina: 哎受不了一点家人们哈哈
Katrina: I can't handle this, guys. Haha.
Shure: 因为我知道
Shure: Because I know.
Katrina: 我说我说你说谁不一样
Katrina: I was like, "Who are you talking about?"
Katrina: 你说我吗
Katrina: "Are you talking about me?"
Katrina: 哈哈对
Katrina: Haha, yeah.
Katrina: 但是我觉得你跟其他人都不太一样
Katrina: But I think you're really different from everyone else.
Katrina: 嗯是不太一样
Katrina: Yeah, definitely different.
Katrina: 我说我
Katrina: I said,
Katrina: 身边
Katrina: around me,
Katrina: 没有找到第二个跟我想法一样的女生
Katrina: there's no one else who thinks like me.
Shure: 陈建辉
Shure: Chen Jianhui.
Shure: 断崖式暧昧
Shure: Abrupt flirtation.
Katrina: 但是我感觉他不是很坚定
Katrina: But I feel like he's not very sure about it.
Katrina: 一会这样一会那样
Katrina: One moment he's like this, the next he's like that.
Katrina: 本来就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Katrina: 然后然后就就是
Katrina: And then, then,
Katrina: 当时就抱着那种必死的决心去见面
Katrina: I went to meet up with him with a do-or-die attitude.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就见面了以后
Katrina: After meeting up,
Katrina: 就本来想的是表白肯定不成功
Katrina: I thought my confession would definitely fail.
Katrina: 人家那那线上都爱答不理的
Katrina: He was so indifferent online.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 然后线下回来以后就对我非常的热情
Katrina: Then after we met offline, he was really enthusiastic towards me.
Katrina: 然后问我什么时候下一次吃饭
Katrina: And then he asked me when we could have dinner again.
Shure: 那他
Shure: So he...
Katrina: 然后我就
Katrina: And then I...
Shure: 那你上次才表白
Shure: But you just confessed last time.
Shure: 然后他又拒绝了
Shure: And he rejected you.
Katrina: 没我让他别说话
Katrina: No, I told him not to talk.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 傻逼
Shure: Idiot.
Shure: 你神经病吧你
Shure: Are you crazy?
Katrina:  哈哈因为因为他
Katrina: Hahaha, because, because he...
Katrina: 他跟我前男友都是你知道
Katrina: He and my ex-boyfriend, you know...
Katrina: 他们俩一发任何一点东西
Katrina: Whenever they post anything...
Katrina: 我就心情就会被他们搅一番
Katrina: It messes with my mood.
Katrina: 我就说你别说话
Katrina: So I told him not to talk.
Katrina: 以后再也不要回话了
Katrina: Never reply again.
Katrina: 然后过两天新年快乐
Katrina: Then, two days later, he said "Happy New Year."
Shure: 哎呦你真
Shure: Oh, you're really...
Shure: 又当又立
Shure: Playing both sides.
Katrina: 无所谓
Katrina: Whatever.
Katrina: 嗯哼
Katrina: Mmm-hmm.
Katrina: 刚又跟我说不想谈恋爱
Katrina: He just told me again that he doesn't want to date.
Katrina: 所以我打算不谈哈哈哈
Katrina: So, I plan not to date, hahaha.
Shure: 哎嗨嗨
Shure: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 有病吧这不是
Katrina: Isn't he crazy?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 或者他不承认
Katrina: Or he just won't admit it.
Katrina: 他现在跟我聊天算什么呢是
Katrina: So, what does he mean by chatting with me now?
Shure: 哦图一乐呗
Shure: Oh, just for fun, I guess.
Katrina: 你知道男生叫什么
Katrina: You know what they call guys like him?
Jake:它这是要干你了
Jake: He's trying to get with you.
Katrina: 叫土相加北邮男
Katrina: 哈哈哈好吧
Katrina: Hahaha, alright.
Shure: 我感觉
Shure: I feel like...
Katrina: 还有很多人说
Katrina: And a lot of people say...
Katrina: 嗯九十月份时候
Katrina: Mmm, back in September and October...
Katrina: 对我就是那种事事有回应到
Katrina: Yeah, I was really responsive to everything.
Katrina: 就是我跟我男朋友前男友在一起5年
Katrina: When I was with my ex for 5 years...
Katrina: 都就是完全超过那个程度
Katrina: It was way beyond that level of detail.
Katrina: 就那种细致程度
Katrina: That kind of meticulousness.
Katrina: 帮我俩出去吃饭
Katrina: Help me go out to eat.
Katrina: 嗯当然穿的VAS磨脚了
Katrina: Hmm, of course, wearing VAS shoes hurts my feet.
Katrina: 因为我点菜的时候
Katrina: Because when I was ordering food,
Katrina: 他就去帮我找创可贴了
Katrina: he went to get me some band-aids.
Katrina: 那种就你不用跟他说
Katrina: You don't even need to tell him.
Katrina: 你稍微可能几个小时说一句话
Katrina: Maybe you say something a few hours before,
Katrina: 几个小时前说一句话他可能就记住了
Katrina: and he might remember it a few hours later.
Katrina: 嗯但我听他也给我讲
Katrina: Hmm, but I listened to him telling me
Katrina: 然后包括我们俩出去玩什么
Katrina: and when we went out to play,
Katrina: 都是他安排
Katrina: he arranged everything.
Katrina: 他就那天玩完了
Katrina: After we finished playing that day,
Katrina: 然后在出租车上有点累两个人没说话
Katrina: we were a bit tired in the taxi and didn't talk.
Katrina: 人说哎火锅消化了好想来一碗
Katrina: Then he said, "Hey, hotpot is digested, I really want a bowl of something."
Katrina: 他是厦门人
Katrina: He's from Xiamen.
Katrina: 然后我说好想来一碗四果汤
Katrina: And I said, "I really want a bowl of four-fruit soup."
Katrina: 就他我不是去厦门玩了
Katrina: It was when I went to Xiamen to play.
Katrina: 四果汤那边的一个那清补凉那种东西
Katrina: Four-fruit soup is something like a clear tonic there.
Katrina: 然后呢他也没怎么说话
Katrina: He didn't say much.
Katrina: 就感觉他话好像不是特别多那种
Katrina: He just seemed like he wasn't very talkative.
Katrina: 然后我再一回头他已经帮我点外卖了
Katrina: Then I turned around and he had already ordered takeout for me.
Jake:这怎么看这很容易看吗
Jake: How do you see this, is it easy to see?
Katrina: 就这种你知道吗
Katrina: You know what I mean?
Katrina: 然后我就特别吃这种
Katrina: I really like this.
Katrina: 我就觉得
Katrina: I just feel
Katrina: 哎呀人家把你那个话什么都放心里
Katrina: that he takes everything I say to heart.
Shure: 好想拿你哎
Shure: I really want to take you away, haha.
Katrina: 嗯是可能这么讲这需要多谈几段
Katrina: Hmm, maybe we need to talk more for this to happen.
Jake:哈这么讲究
Jake: Ha, so particular.
Katrina: 然后我觉得他刚和
Katrina: Then I think he just
Katrina: 应该是对我有一点喜欢
Katrina: might like me a little bit.
Katrina: 但是我不知道他为什么后来就这样
Katrina: But I don't know why he acted like that later.
Shure: 不他我感觉就是我们家有只大蚯蚓被
Shure: No, I feel like we have a big earthworm at home.
Shure: 你某一个特质就是
Shure: It's like a trait of yours.
Shure: 至于到那种谈恋爱那个地步
Shure: Whether it reaches the level of a relationship,
Shure: 可能我不知道有没有
Shure: I don't know if it will.
Katrina: 搞不懂所以我要问清楚吗
Katrina: I don't get it, so I need to ask him clearly.
Shure: 因为我我们21号办这个活动
Shure: Because we're having this event on the 21st.
Katrina: 22号什么时候散
Katrina: When does it end on the 22nd?
Katrina: 因为我要想要买票嘛
Katrina: Because I need to buy a ticket.
Katrina: 不知道 22号还要在这呆一整天嘛
Katrina: I don't know, do we have to stay here the whole day on the 22nd?
Shure: 不要了
Shure: No more.
Katrina: 白天
Katrina: In the daytime.
Shure: 21号收尾工作之后你就可以走了啊
Shure: After you finish up on the 21st, you can go.
Katrina: 他说22号 22号
Katrina: He said the 22nd, the 22nd.
Katrina: 昨天问他干嘛
Katrina: I asked him yesterday what he's doing.
Katrina: 他说摸鱼
Katrina: He said slacking off.
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Shure: 对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 昨天不是亏死了一圈吗
Katrina: Didn't we lose a lot yesterday?
Shure: 22号应该就是收拾完然后就走
Shure: On the 22nd, we should finish up and then leave.
Katrina: 嗯 22号收拾一下
Katrina: Yeah, tidy up on the 22nd.
Katrina: 所以我就觉得
Katrina: So I was thinking...
Katrina: 到底是22号晚上约他吃饭呢
Katrina: Should I ask him to dinner on the night of the 22nd...
Katrina: 还是23号晚上约他
Katrina: Or the night of the 23rd?
Katrina: 约一下然后第二天白天可以走
Katrina: Ask him out, then he can leave the next day.
Katrina: 就是觉得百分百被拒绝
Katrina: I just feel like I'll definitely get rejected.
Katrina: 然后就结果那玩意学校的事也很多
Katrina: And then there are a lot of things at school too.
Katrina: 分析分析呗哥
Katrina: Analyze it for me, bro.
Shure: 反正我这几年不像吗
Shure: Haven't I been like this for years?
Katrina: 不是土相的吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Aren't you an earth sign? Hahaha.
Shure: 没闲着
Shure: Never idle.
Shure: 经常会有那种断崖式什么
Shure: There's often that kind of cliff-like...
Shure: 就断崖式暧昧
Shure: Cliff-like ambiguity.
Shure: 这种
Shure: That kind.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Shure: 就是跟一个女生暧昧
Shure: Like being ambiguous with a girl...
Shure: 突然就
Shure: And then suddenly...
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Katrina: 你啊
Katrina: You?
Katrina: 你们同学是为什么呢
Katrina: Why is it with your classmates?
Shure: 也不是我就感觉双方都是这个样子
Shure: It's not just me, it feels like both sides are like that.
Shure: 就有的时候可能是我热脸贴冷屁股
Shure: Sometimes it feels like I'm being overly eager.
Shure: 而且我有个特别傻逼的一点
Shure: And I have a particularly stupid point.
Shure: 就是我原来那个
Shure: Back in my freshman year...
Shure: 尤其大一的那时候
Shure: Especially in my freshman year.
Shure: 大一大二的时候
Shure: Freshman and sophomore years.
Shure: 就老控制不好自己酒量
Shure: I couldn't control my drinking.
Shure: 然后有的时候就是
Shure: And sometimes...
Shure: 跟室友喝着喝着
Shure: Drinking with my roommates...
Shure: 喝多了
Shure: I'd get too drunk.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 然后我就会
Shure: And then I would
Katrina: 给人打电话
Katrina: Call people
Shure: 也不是打电话
Shure: Not really call
Shure: 就发一堆奇奇怪怪的语音
Shure: Just send a bunch of weird voice messages
Shure: 我靠然后
Shure: Damn, and then
Shure: 然后就基本这种情况下
Shure: In these situations, basically
Shure: 第二天就再也不想见了
Shure: The next day, I wouldn't want to meet again
Shure: 但是神奇的是
Shure: But the funny thing is
Shure: 这种情况之后都没有删这些人
Shure: After these situations, I never deleted these people
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Katrina: 你也蛮抽象的
Katrina: You're pretty abstract
Katrina: 然后第二天你们还会聊天吗
Katrina: And the next day, do you still chat?
Shure: 不会那个我那个有
Shure: No, that... I had one
Shure: 之前有一个就是一直聊的很好的吧
Shure: There was one that I chatted really well with, right?
Shure: 算是
Shure: Kind of
Shure: 然后就是开学之后就是想约他再见面
Shure: And then after school started, I wanted to meet up again
Shure: 然后就一直没约到
Shure: But never got to meet
Shure: 就是暑假之前跟他认识
Shure: Met them before the summer break
Katrina: 一个学校的吗
Katrina: Same school?
Shure: 对一个学校的
Shure: Yeah, same school
Katrina: 他妈一个学校的都进来这么慢
Katrina: Damn, both from the same school, and it took this long?
Katrina: 要我直接
Katrina: If it were me, I'd just...
Katrina: 哎口嗨
Katrina: Ugh, just talk big
Katrina: 哈哈你三个月都没确认关系呢
Katrina: Haha, you haven't confirmed the relationship in three months?
Katrina: 我还在这口嗨
Katrina: I'm still just talking big
Shure: 差不多都都一样嗨
Shure: Pretty much the same, all just talk
Katrina: 主要武汉理工真没看到喜欢的
Katrina: Mainly, I haven't seen anyone I like at Wuhan University of Technology
Katrina: 好奇怪啊
Katrina: So weird
Katrina: 看了四年没看到
Katrina: Four years and still haven't seen
Shure: 可能是要穿的比较
Shure: Maybe you need to dress more
Shure: 不对那你有各种艺术团什么的
Shure: No, but you have all kinds of art groups and stuff
Katrina: 嗯有啊
Katrina: Yeah, we have those
Shure: 反正我就每几乎每一个时间段都会
Shure: Anyway, I almost always
Shure: 找一个类似于这样的
Shure: Find someone similar to that
Katrina: 关系
Katrina: Relationship
Shure: 暧昧对象的关系吧算是对
Shure: An ambiguous relationship, I guess
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Ugh
Shure: 我甚至有更离谱的
Shure: I even have more ridiculous ones
Shure: 比如说那种就是那种两个人都
Shure: Like those, where both people...
Shure: 亲过了然后都那种谈的
Shure: We've kissed and talked about everything.